all right guys bang-bang I've got you
seen here he is coming to us live I
guess kind of from Morocco so thanks
much for doing this thanks for having me
it's it's an honor to be here for sure
let's jump in how long have you been at
arc invest and kind of what you know for
those that don't know just your
investment philosophy in general sure so
I joined arc in July of 2018 right after
college I'm definitely not an OG Bitcoin
er so I don't have any stories about you
know hi about a hundred Bitcoin lost my
private keys or anything like that
so my break into Bitcoin was actually
happening kind of serendipitously over
overlap with my general approach to
college and finding a job and really
kind of figuring out what I wanted to do
in my first few years of college I
definitely knew what I didn't want to do
and I know you have a recent you had a
recent podcast with David parrell that
kind of talks about his break into
figuring out what he wanted to do a lot
of what he does over left but I would I
would I kind of broke how I broke into
it and effectively I walked into like an
info session I met my freshman year
everyone was kind of wearing a suit
everyone kind of had an accompanied
stack of business cards with them and
they were truly literally Fork Reuters
Investment Banking and consulting and
kind of getting one step closer to
landing that interview to get that
summer job once you get that summer job
you kind of land that full-time job and
then from there you basically and so
realizing this I kind of told myself
that I didn't want to fall into this
track and that there was definitely kind
of another way to do that and so in
college I I studied this engineering and
finance and so I kind of knew I didn't
want to invest in consulting but at the
same time kind of wanted to apply both
the kind of
finance side of things and system
engineering side of things to figure out
some sort of overlap my junior year of
college I interned at a venture capital
fund and they kind of typically don't
really hire first-year analysts so very
quickly I realized that there was only
so much added value that I could provide
beyond just kind of basic KPIs and an
industry analysis and then that's where
kind of crypto and Bitcoin came in where
I had kind of heard of crypto through
the grapevine but I never really had the
opportunity to dig deep this was at the
time kind of before the SEO boom and so
I kind of asked the partners at my BC if
I could kind of look into crypto from
both the technical perspective and then
realized very very quickly that this was
really a small but growing market that
was underestimated and so I found out
that you know in a very few things where
expertise and experience doesn't matter
I found that crypto was one of those
things and so throughout the remainder
of my college I kind of learned
obsessively about kind of Bitcoin and
told myself that this is kind of what I
want to do full time into space I was
definitely by no means an expert but
that summer I kind of created a Twitter
account started sharing interesting
ideas and actually stumbled across art
through Twitter and so I know you had
Kathy on on the podcast a a few days ago
there we go it's going to be published
and well she kind of founded art based
on kind of two premises the first was
that kind of the research that knew the
way that research was set up and kind of
traditional asset management firms
there's kind of a huge huge lack of that
and in particular the way that asset
management firms kind of set up their
research in a way that the compliance is
set up to kind of affect that research
is very very limited in terms of how
that research can then be used and
shared and so you know a combination of
that in kind of technological disruptive
for disruption and disruptive innovation
more broadly made it such that she kind
of she found an arc in in 25th 2015 and
focused exclusive focus exclusively on
disruptive innovation and and across
kind of a wide array of what we call
kind of technology platforms of those
technology platforms is kind of crypto
and blockchain so arc in particular
Kathy's relationship with Bitcoin
actually predates our expounding so you
know in the most recent interview Kathy
mentioned that she had this weekly
brainstorm session where she and and and
the analyst kind of gather every week to
discuss any provocative news and he
breakthroughs and research and so it was
actually back in her time at Alliance
Bernstein in late 2011 when the first
kind of brainstorm session was conduct
conducted about Bitcoin
obviously at the time we were kind of
far from any means to gain any sort of
exposure the fast forward to 2015 when
when arc really started to take Bitcoin
seriously and we published kind of our
first white paper on if Bitcoin could
kind of serve the three rolls of money
and then a few years later we took our
first position in gbtc or the grayscale
Bitcoin investment trust when Bitcoin
started to trade around $200 and then a
few months after that we published a
second white paper on Bitcoin
that's really the birth of a new asset
class at the time when kind of crisp
risky he was now a placeholder I was
kind of leading the the research there
and so we kind of we give this question
a lot because we one of the first
investors in quote-unquote gbtc or the
first kind of public fund manager to
gain explorative Bitcoin but we don't
actually hold any any underlying Bitcoin
and our exposure to the kind of crypto
opportunity more broadly is actually
exclusively in kind of public companies
that offer potentially interesting
derivatives but
yes so let's talk a little bit about how
you guys are gaining that exposure and
then we could talk more I think about
just institutional investors in general
but starting with you guys so your
investors in gbtc then you invest in a
number of other businesses almost
exclusively in the public markets and
those publicly traded companies maybe
something like a square that has a
number of different products or kind of
revenue streams one of them could be
Bitcoin right so you almost get like
indirect exposure to Bitcoin through a
business that benefits from Bitcoin as a
product or something that they offer and
then combine that with the gbtc you're
really kind of getting exposure in
multiple ways that correct that's
exactly right so there are definitely
public companies that offer interesting
derivatives Botox crypto and you know
square is actually one of our highest
conviction names where you know squares
primary business model has nothing
really necessarily to do with Bitcoin or
crypto but when you actually dig deep
into potential kind of revenue streams
down the line you start to realize how
interesting the opportunities there
there there are so actually part of our
research and part of our thesis is that
you have these technology platforms that
are kind of converging and so the idea
of having like a traditional tech
analyst or traditional auto analyst or
traditional energy analyst in this new
world does not necessarily fit and so
when you kind of look at like a company
like square there's so many kind of
different ways where you can tackle the
investment pieces so obviously the one
that a lot of snow is kind of a high
level you have these retail banks that
pay between you know 350 and 1,500
dollars to partner customers and you you
contrast that with a company like square
which has one of the most you know
popular digital wallets in the cash app
which has a customer acquisition cost of
around $20 and so this goes back
actually to one of Arc's overarching
theses which is around this idea that
cost declines are a primary force behind
technologically enabled disruption and
so the same holds true in consumer
making and so our
our FinTech analyst so I'll actually
cover Square to stop it or FinTech
analyst max friedrich has the incredible
work on how this kind of unlocks a
massive market where you say that
there's let's say 20 million people in
the US we're still unbanked to put this
kind of into perspective you know
Citibank has 20 million customer
accounts in the u.s. today and we use
what's really interesting to see is when
you see the comparison of the FDIC's on
bank rates and we will search friends
for squares cash up which that max that
a lot of work on there's a very
compelling kind of Geographic overlap
that that nice makes it such that you
know cash at dominates the southern
states where the rates of the unbanked
are highest
um you have kind of these features like
direct deposit which square introduced
in 2018 that in let's cash out users
generate these kind of routing and
account numbers that you would kind of
get in normal checking accounts and then
they can then pass that on to to
facilitate the deposit to their own
employers and you can basically spend
paychecks from your cash at balance with
a debit card that cash at issues and so
when you combine that with an extremely
savvy network based marketing strategy
with a clear product roadmap you
basically come to what could be a fully
functional digital bag
they've built a robust user base
targeting specific consumer networks you
have extremely sticky p2p payments and
and so there's a growing realization
that that most banking functions can
basically mark migrate it to your iPhone
notice how none of that Bitcoin that
Bitcoin ever really come up and so then
you layer on top of that you know
something like big point where you look
at Jack Dorsey as being the only CEO I
would save to public companies that
truly understands bitcoins value
proposition and I've said it before and
I'll say it again I think that we can't
underestimate the role kind of square
Jack are playing and kind of bringing
Bitcoin to the masses and there are a
few interesting angles that Square has
taken and it's involved in Bitcoin that
I think is very unique I mean at one
level you have let's say you know the
cash app providing an you know easy
interface to buy sell send Bitcoin and
and you know what's interesting is that
the cash up isn't like a big point first
product and so it's almost like a oh by
the way there is a another Avenue by
which you can learn about Bitcoin and
it's through the cash shop and you
already have to catch up battle it on
your phone and so there's this
educational on-ramp and and normalizing
a Bitcoin that I think that Square is
doing that many people don't yet realize
and then on the on the flip side of that
you have something like you know a year
ago where we're square set up let's say
square crypto and that is basically a
separate corporate entity whose really
sole function is to sponsor Bitcoin
developers and further the Bitcoin
ecosystem so kinda foregoing short-term
profits for kind of the the the the
benefit of Bitcoin and so having a
public company and that has to appeal to
ships Terran shareholders that then
acknowledges that you know ultimately
we're long-term investors and Bitcoin
success Square success is is a really
really interesting kind of angle that I
think that very few public companies
have the foresight to to take and so
when you combine that with the fact that
Square also has access to millions of
merchants they could end up
hypothetically cutting out card networks
entirely if you have both the customer
and the merchant we're on board and in
doing so that using potentially Bitcoin
as a settlement layer and so there are
several layers to this so that that's
kind of how we view view square more
broadly and I think that you know it's a
very very interesting unique way of
getting kind of that derivative exposure
to the Bitcoin opportunity for sure and
then maybe talk a little bit about gbtc
and
and kind of the other end of that
argument right so you get the exposure
through public companies that are kind
of derivatives of Bitcoin but then you
also go and you get direct exposure
although you guys aren't holding the
Bitcoin you know gbtc technically is
holding it for you what's the logic
there sure so the gbtc is traded
basically over the counter it's a it's a
trust where you you is for one only one
of our ETS holds gbtc and that
end-to-end we have kind of specific
restrictions on how much gbtc we can
actually hold and Kathy kind of went
into detail that and last episode but
basically at a high level it's more than
10% of gross profits are attributed to
let's say gpgc or any commodity then
anything above that 10% is kind of
deemed unqualified income and that's
kind of just the very nature of how the
product is set up so given that we are
kind of an SEC registered or for our AAA
there are only specific products that we
can hold in our portfolios so we can't
necessarily just hold like custody
Bitcoin private keys and say that we
have explored to the big point and so
gbtc given that it trades over the
counter and allows us to get kind of
that exposure but obviously there are
trade-offs to the specific to the
specific product so for instance you
know everything from kind of additional
management fees that are incurred with
something like gbtc to kind of the
premium that gbtc has as a function of
its kind of redemption or lack thereof
and so there is a so so effectively it
trades on the secondary markets you have
to be in a credit investor if you want
to go through the trust at nav and then
you have a what what is now a six month
lockup period in which then you can
attempt to harvest that premium when it
then trades on the secondary markets and
so as an ETF we kind of buy and sell on
the on the secondary
markets and so have kind of that
exposure to the premium on the
volatility and but but at the same time
this is really kind of the only product
that is that is really out there that
allows for us to get exposure I'll be
limited and with its own kind of
inefficiencies yeah makes a ton of sense
help us understand like as you guys are
thinking through gbtc or square or other
companies like you guys obviously have a
position on Bitcoin and crypto in
general so forget about how you're
getting the exposure like like what is
that philosophy that auric has around
Bitcoin and crypto in general sure so I
would say it's definitely evolved over
time I would say that in general if we
kind of take a step back and look at
kind of the different philosophies of
the crypto space more broadly you have
kind of this two salient distinctions
between between kind of basically two
camps you have you know at the simplest
level tech versus money or what I like
to call kind of the innovation
maximalist versus the monetary Maximus
on the innovation Maximus side
you basically have a camp that views
these networks as kind of software first
and so they could look at the killer app
as being these multi-sided market places
where kind of the primary consideration
for or investor focus is really around
expressive upgradeable kind of
composable base layers with extremely
large feature sets in which the network
infrastructure priority is kind of
around scalability and so when you take
that premise when you got that premise
you look at Bitcoin as really just the
slow boring kind of reliable thing that
just does something extremely simply and
so isn't you know if there's an
interesting quote from from an a 16g
partner that basically says like you
know if Bitcoin is really the only thing
that can come out of this or
we basically a failure and so on the
other side of that you have kind of what
I deemed kind of the monitoring max
lists where if you look at these crypto
assets from a value cruel standpoint and
you understand really what these are and
these are not kind of productive assets
these are really effectively money or
kind of money obfuscated by
technological jargon then then you
realize that the killer app is not
necessarily these multi cited
marketplaces that bootstrap that had
these bootstrap mini economies but are
rather the killer app is really money
and so if the killer app is money the
investor focus should be really around
kind of having a network that provides
specific assurances to maintaining that
monetary integrity and so by doing so
your your your infrastructure your
network priority is no longer around
kind of feature sets and scalability but
rather is around kind of the ability to
five these assurances to wealth and the
ability to do so in a very trust
minimized manner and so as we kind of
you know Kathy as it has a pretty strong
monetary economics background and that
means that had dough into where most
values going to prove we kind of tend to
focus more heavily on kind of the
monetary maxima side where you kind of
look at these as as effectively money
and that that money tends to or
currencies more broadly tend to be
natural monopolies and so this tends to
be kind of a winner takes most if not
all game and the winner is going to be
not one that kind of condensed by on
features because ultimately in the open
source world you know tech the tech side
of things I think is highly commoditized
but those that kind of provide extremely
strong assurances that are kind of
almost be replicable and when you kind
of spin up it a new network and so
that's why you know we have extremely
strong conviction and Bitcoin
specifically you know that's why are
focused on research kind of remains on
Bitcoin
and kind of had a view these and what we
like to call new novel social economic
institutions as as as monetary kind of
as a mechanism by which you can reliably
neutrally and permission this the kind
of store and transfer value yeah and I
think what you're talking about here is
like there's this element of money's a
belief system right and all the features
in the world can be replicated but
people just don't believe in that
actually being the currency of choice or
the currency that holds value the
features are relatively unimportant to
some degree process it I think that
what's interesting to see is you know
when you when you take a step back and
you see all the experimentation that's
been done and all that kind of
misallocated capital we see that the
engineers the tech gurus really just
took a monetary revolution for a
software technological one and it's been
really interesting to see kind of the
different mindsets that I would say are
still prevalent today but that don't
really recognize these as kind of
political and social experiments first
but rather as kind of this new gadget or
this software that has specific kind of
tech implementation details that
something like Bitcoin could never
provide so you kind of like think about
you know if only you know we could
create the more efficient database there
if only kind of Bitcoin was faster only
you know there was a different monetary
policy to Bitcoin and that kind of
dismisses the underlying questions to
what makes Bitcoin and is so unique in
to your point to some degree the way
that kind of a monetary good accrues
value is exclusively based on
reservation to matter the willingness to
hold the asset and that willingness to
hold the asset is kind of based on kind
of the network effects that it has
related that you speculate will it will
have and that in itself I don't think is
a kind of non arbitrary belief I think
that belief is backed by
specific again assurances that that
network can provide so everything from
kind of the credibility of monetary
policy to the the assurance that that
the asset itself won't be kind of
arbitrarily seized or frozen that you
know that the transactions won't be
censored that the value can actually be
seamlessly stored and transferred so all
these things kind of create this this
feedback loop that too many seems
circular but that at the end of the day
there is a reason why kind of Bitcoin is
the most liquid that there is a reason
why Bitcoin has the strongest network
effect and and and so in and that is
because of the the explicit trade-offs
that it has had in saying okay we are
going to have a hard extremely
predictable monetary policy this is
going to be slow but it's going to be
extremely secure and it's going to do a
few things but it's going to do a few
things extremely reliably and so that's
kind of that's kind of where we're I
think investors are starting to realize
that there's going to be kind of a shift
from look at how many look at how many
features that this network can provide
for me versus look at just a few
features that it could provide reliably
yeah it's super interesting what are you
guys thoughts on bitcoins reaction to
the liquidity crisis or liquidity trap
that was caused by kovat so obviously
there was this massive sell-off in most
asset classes Bitcoin at one point kind
of that Black Thursday or whatever you
want to call it sold off 50% ended the
day down about 30 there's a lot of
people who are saying hey this looks
pretty correlated to me and also it
doesn't look like so much of a safe
haven type asset kind of how do you guys
look at what was transpired over the
last six weeks or so sure so I'd say
we're still very far from returning to
kind of business as usual so there's
questions definitely that remain as to
you know when we'll get back on our on
the horse and and then like I really
know the timetable there is but I think
it's been very interesting to your point
to see kind of bitcoins response to
ooh kind of the recent uncertainty we
there's some great work that's been put
out by you know the coin metrics of the
world is a recent piece from the CEO of
X PTO who shares his views I think there
are a few things that we need to
consider here first is that what in a
crisis whether it's coronavirus or
financial crisis or geopolitical crisis
there's always a crisis of liquidity and
there's a vicious cycle that occurs
where you have basically over levered
investors who need to sell across asset
classes across every asset class and
that creates kind of a rush to liquidity
where the comfort of cash basically
drives relations to one and I say this
because I think it's been interesting to
see how we've seen this evolution of
narratives around Bitcoin during
coronavirus where to your point there
has been these two competing narratives
that have now been heavily questioned
during this first quarter
the first is again Bitcoin as this
uncorrelated financial asset second is
Bitcoin as this kind of safe haven asset
when we look back at the month of March
I don't think people were expecting to
see it as severe the drop as what we saw
it was cramming Bitcoin suffered its
second largest daily draw down in price
history and I think it was less than 15
minutes you saw it go from 7,200 down to
5400 it broke it's 200 moving average
for the first time in seven years and
then can continue to sink below 4k and
post sell up we realized that one of the
largest contributors was likely be kind
of these Bitcoin liquidations to satisfy
margin calls on kind of bit Nexus of the
world or you saw a bit Nick's on Black
Thursday had almost a billion dollars in
liquidations which is the most over a
24-hour period and in years and you
combine that with kind of the exchange
outages that it saw and all the
uncertainty around
groaning coronavirus and so you kind of
get this kind of natural self what was
interesting to see and you actually
mentioned this with Kathy was that it
appears that the speculators were
flushed out and that longer term
investors continued to hold and and so
for true leaders in Bitcoin the
fundamentals haven't changed and when
you dig into the numbers in coin metrics
show it shows this some of the most most
of the sellers were actually short term
holders and so if you take a look at
bitcoins revive supply which is how many
old coins came back into circulation
after being untouched for a specific
period of time the vast majority of of
the activity involved Bitcoin that had
been that that had been held for less
than a year and so this kind of suggests
that long-term holders really appeared
on faced at the same time you had this
sell-off that was severe and it wasn't
tandem with nepeta market sell-off and
so there are legitimate questions that
are raised around bitcoins if bitcoin is
worthy of allocation if its claim to
fame narrative is around its non
correlation and it's safe haven
attributes if dig into the numbers
though historically bitcoin has been
relatively uncorrelated with let's say
the S&P since since 2012
the correlation has been roughly between
negative point 15 to point 15 which is
pretty low correlation over this last
month that kind of increased to new
all-time highs and so the question then
becomes does the recent correlation then
justify people saying that bitcoin and
S&P are now suddenly correlated and the
answer I would say as many would say is
probably not and so although you saw
these short-term correlations shoot up
you have to recognize that they were
under very unique market circumstances
you had the news of the spreading of the
corona buyers that continue to grow you
saw investors across every asset class
rushing into cash and back to
to my earlier point in any risk off
environment it seems like there's really
no safety especially not something
that's like you know has this thing of
order books as something like Bitcoin
that where a lot of the activity and
training activity is driven by
speculation but I mean we even saw this
with gold right the correlation between
the SPD and gold was also tie since 2013
and so I think that we're going to see
some sort of kind of reversion to the
mean between Bitcoin and SP but that in
the short term there may very well be
kind of strong high correlation between
the two on the safe-haven asset side I
would say you know gold has
traditionally been used as that primary
example of the safe-haven asset and many
like to coin Bitcoin as a digital gold
and so you know usually in uncertain
times you see the price of gold
increased relative to other asset
classes and in Bitcoin and Gold's
correlation historically has been
relatively low like they haven't had
there hasn't been very strong
correlation in fact at the extremes
they've been negative and so when we saw
Bitcoin and bullets correlation also
spiked up in March similar to Bitcoin in
S&P and Bouldin SP you know does that
mean that gold will also fail as a
safe-haven asset and and I would say the
answer there is also probably not where
you you start to realize that although
Bitcoin and gold may not act as
safe-haven assets during kind of a
little pandemic they may act as a
safe-haven asset you know in times of
monetary inflation or QE and so you know
let's say given the reason trillion
dollar injections that we've seen from
the Fed it's possible that you have big
point like gold that may act as a safe
haven response to some events but not
others and so that's kind of where where
I where I stand with kind of
our reaction where it's like you know we
could be in the midst of what could be
an interesting inflection point where if
we continued to see kind of central
banks inject these money into the
economy at these rates then you know
then it could act as that safe haven
during that particular shock but really
the broader point is that fundamentals
haven't changed that they're nice that
bitcoin is still working as designed
it's producing roughly you know you know
a block every ten minutes it has an
audible transparent supply and it
enables kind of permissionless more
engine transfer value so yeah and it
feels like the the whole argument around
correlation non correlation the first
thing that just blows my mind is you
have people to share on Twitter and
stuff but holding up to charts back when
these two charts look like they look
similar okay and it's like no
correlation is actually a math equation
so people won't have to realize like
there's actually math that goes into
this and we were talking there about
kind of 0.15 down to negative point one
five is a way to quantify how correlated
these two assets are on top of that I
love the example of well gold and
Treasuries in real estate equities and
everything's sold off so does that mean
that there is no such thing as a safe
haven asset then right other than maybe
the dollar and what I think people have
to understand is like we're still in the
middle of the crisis so if you go back
to 2008 2009 when gold sold off 29
percent over the summer of o8 what does
everyone doing yelling and screaming
goals the longer say haven asset but all
of a sudden if you then zoom out to the
full lifetime of the crisis pulled ends
up over 300 percent right hits an
all-time high and so I think it's really
hard to kind of make these
determinations or
form opinions in the middle of the
crisis because you don't have all the
data of the hindsight of being able to
look back and say well this is what
happened throughout the entire thing
because what you think you know six to
eight weeks in it's probably not going
to be what you think on the conclusion
of this for better or for worse right
because you're going to get more data
and that has a high probability of
actually changing your mind or what your
assumptions or conclusions are I mean I
think you bring up a
broader point where even on a returns
basis so many people like to look at
specific time frames and cherry-pick
specific returns and and and Bitcoin
particularly receive is so often but
it's like you know you if you are a
long-term investor and I think that you
know especially with these these things
that are so volatile it's in your best
interest to be as long-term as possible
it's like you got to take a step back
and look at kind of longer-term holding
periods so when you do provide that
extra context in that extra context
being kind of a length and time horizon
then things start to look things start
to look a lot more attractive and so
that's kind of I think a fallacy that a
lot of shorter term investors and
particularly traders fall into where
they look at one immediate reaction and
they think that you know everything
prior to that is now now needs to be
completely dismissed and this is our new
reality so just different different kind
of perspective on time periods as well
for sure you guys have done a bunch of
work on Bitcoin mining and - research
there maybe talk a little bit about the
work you guys have done and some of the
conclusions you guys have come to based
on that research sure so we we've done a
lot of work on Bitcoin I think Bitcoin
mining is one of them one of the areas
of research where I kind of really done
thank you earlier on we recently
published a white paper kind of laying
out kind of the different the state of
Bitcoin mining where you kind of start
out with you know what is Bitcoin mining
and what is proof of work and it's proof
of work computationally intensive or or
is it just you know they're by design
and then go into kind of the evolution
of mining Hardware looking at each kind
of layer of the supply chain and
realising kind of where competitive
advantages exist where they are kind of
increasingly becoming less relevant and
then coming up with some sort of
interesting overarching conclusion that
kind of Bitcoin mining is is here to
stay but that it is increasingly going
to become kind of commoditized or
to replicate returns very similar to
what we have seen in the commodities
industry where today kind of Bitcoin
mining is is profitable but highly
volatile highly uncertain attracts kind
of a pool of capital that I would say is
more risk seeking but as kind of the as
you see kind of depth in capital markets
as you see lengths and hardware cycles
as you see more predictability around
the economics of mining that that kind
of the levels of profitability or are
going to kind of accent totally converge
to something that would be more
attractive for let's say risk neutral or
something more conservative who wants to
kind of replicate a traditional or
typical kind of cash flow business that
offers kind of low and consistent
returns and so when you get and when you
get like a more mature derivatives
market and when you get kind of more
predictability on hardware and the
economics you start to unlock I would
say pools of capital that today would be
kind of less interested in Bitcoin
mining and then and so it remains kind
of a a fundamental kind of part of what
makes Bitcoin secure and and it's
something that I think increasingly
you'll have pools of capital that that
today don't have exposure that will kind
of increasingly have exposure a an area
of research on that point that I
recently dug into with my analyst with
our industrial analyst Sam he we asked
kind of what what do the economics of
mining look like for let's say like
let's say natural gas eager plant where
to mine Bitcoin with its excess capacity
so kind of to take a step back and
provide context this is this area of
research was initially triggered from an
article that was published on Bloomberg
last month in early March where you had
news
natural gas speaker plant in upstate New
York I think they were called Greenwich
generation that announced as part of the
plant renovation that they were going to
be deploying kind of thousands of mining
rigs that would be used to mine Bitcoin
with unutilized capacity and so people
have are increasingly seeing seeking
ways to mine Bitcoin and so we asked
ourselves you know if this application
particular had the potential to become
widespread and what the economics of
basically carrying Bitcoin mining with
low utilization power plant would yield
so peaker plants they're they're
typically they typically only operate on
the hottest and coldest days of the year
when there's peak demand for energy
hence their name peaker plant and so as
a result the capacity utilization of an
average peaker plant ends up being about
10% so another way to think about that
is that you basically have peaker plants
that are typically only running on 10%
of the electricity possible relative to
it having run 24/7 so what this means is
you basically have these peaker plants
that have highly variable cash flows
highly variable profitability and if
there are no hot or cold days of the
year then the pker plan is effectively
deemed useless and so what if instead of
you know instead of just turning off or
shutting down the peaker plant on days
where there is no demand you you mind
Bitcoin instead like what would the
economics look like there and so we kind
of built on a model that baked into a
bunch of assumptions where you can
basically a high level divide beyond
analysis into two you look at what the
return on capital of a peeker plant
would look like without mining Bitcoin
versus what what it would look like with
mining Bitcoin so without mining Bitcoin
you basically kind of back into an
estimation on the operating
and maintenance costs you take a low
capacity utilization and you you try to
calculate what the levelized cost of
electricity would need to be and then
any additional capital cost there and
you you roughly yield like a twelve
percent return on invested capital which
is about the median return on investment
capital across industries and is is
actually higher on the higher end for
utilities project and then on the mining
side you basically have the sump shion's
that are threefold you know an
assumption on kind of your mining
operations on mining hardware and on the
Bitcoin network itself so you if you
assume you have the most cost efficient
Hardware on that hardware has like a
depreciation depreciation roughly every
four years lifetime value every four
years and you're incurring a cost to
maintain that hardware and you combine
that with kind of assumptions on price
and hash rate you get a you actually
calculate a return on invested capital
of around nineteen percent and so if you
net the two and you combine the
investment capital you go from a twelve
percent return investment capital of
just a peaker plant without Bitcoin
mining to a weighted seventeen percent
return on invested capital
obviously there are assumption with
bitcoins price and and growth and hash
rate but but really this is a really
interesting way that investors could
plan operation started exploring as
providing additional uncorrelated
sources of revenue um where in the case
of the peaker plant the result is not
just increased returns from mining
Bitcoin but you also get a more
profitable core business from these
lower costs of capital and so you're
adding this new source of revenue in
Bitcoin mining and you're lowering your
operational risk and you're delivering
more consistent returns and when you
think about this in the context of how
Bitcoin mining has evolved from like you
know hobbyist activity where CPU is
drawn from desktops to having these
highly specialized data centers that
perform
kind of operations using an exclusive
hardware it's like their he's very very
interesting secondary effects of the
Bitcoin network that have spawned entire
industries that we today like can only
can only recognize in hindsight and I
think that increasingly we're going to
start to see these innovative ways of
figuring out kind of how to continue to
kind of support the Bitcoin network
while also kind of adding sources of
revenue and profitability in other areas
that don't have Directive don't have
like a direct link to kind of Bitcoin
I'm gonna turn on my light yeah and I
think that part of this now
as you do the equation on if I'm a power
producer should I start to explore
Bitcoin mining as a revenue source the
price of oil all of a sudden tanking
makes it even more interesting right
because there's certain power producers
or our energy producers who say wait a
second if I take these Goods and I sell
them into a market where the price is
literally falling off a cliff today were
you know seeing ten dollars or so for a
barrel of oil which sounds insane like
they're making better uses of my my
power right and that's not obviously
everyone in the energy production world
but but definitely that goes into some
of the equation as well I would think
right absolutely I mean this is really
just only one application of how to kind
of utilize something like a power plant
to figure out ways to mind Bitcoin but I
mean to your point there are so many
other avenues that that people are
exploring whether it's kind of the
stranded energy assets that you see in
hydro whether it's kind of just you know
you know flares and that's what less gas
flares that you're seeing the upstream
data there they're working on words
where you know there's a question of oh
wow bitcoin is like so wasteful and and
look at all the energy that it that it
that it's consuming without recognizing
that nurse and
very unique innovative pockets of energy
that otherwise would have been dumped
and sometimes dumped at a loss that can
now be used to you know convert
electricity into a our monetary accident
and so you know that combined with I
think even you know institutions are
starting to realize that as well what's
interesting is you know cm II a public
company they're in there in exchange
they they actually you know cash-settled
futures listed they recently um had like
an annual kind of board meeting election
where one of the nominees actually made
the case for the need to diversify
revenue streams within the cme by mining
things like big point where it makes
sense similar to how you see kind of a
lot of let's say oil traders who
actually have exposure to the underlying
kind of raise to offset some of the
volatility exposure you're likely going
to see that with something like big
point where you want kind of exposure to
every layer of the stack to create much
more consistent and reliable and it
returns on capital and i think really
this is only the the beginning stages of
that it will be interesting to see kind
of how bitcoin stands the test of kind
of this disinflationary monetary policy
and and the economics of mining Bitcoin
as we kind of go into let's say a fee a
fee reward-based yeah it's gonna be
super interesting what are the thoughts
on a bitcoin having that's coming up
here yes so I I think it's it's gonna be
very interesting there is a a you know a
huge debate on this about kind of its
impact on bitcoins price Laura you
broadly have kind of two camps that are
formed you have one that kind of
believes that the having
it's already pressed in you kind of
citing Martin efficient-market
hypothesis and then you have the other
candidate that expects kind of happening
to plant the seed for what is an
increase in perceived scarcity and a
change in supply side dynamics are kind
of like a supply shock so you know
historically in Bitcoin has only seen
two having's we've seen that that that
it has been this sort of catalyst or
interesting there's been an interesting
overlap between a halving and a run in
price or kind of a catalyst for kind of
the next bull run but but again you know
whether that's a coincidence or whether
that's you know a law that is baked into
nature you know you you get you get it
back and forth I think that I kind of
there there's a few things that I know
will likely happen for sure one I think
we're definitely going to see kind of
minor but selling pressure where unless
you do see kind of a Bitcoin doubling
prices will you know you're going to see
kind of a decline in the break-even
price for a set of miners and so these
miners are likely going to have to
either temporarily or permanently shut
off their their operations we saw that
with kind of the recent difficulty
adjustment and and so that will you will
likely see a drop in hash rate if kind
of bitcoins price does not see that run
up but then the the counter to that is
like if you assume kind of carts of
demand and almost equal then then
assuming that you have a a cut in your
supply then you effectively have kind of
half the supply now needs to be absorbed
by it by the market versus the vs. prior
to the halving and so the remainder is
kind of blend into the circulating
supply and so that's kind of like
at the very least a run-up that many
people argue is going to occur where you
know you now need only half of what what
previously needed to be absorbed by the
market after Bitcoin having and then and
then another thing is that you know
there is this interesting selling point
around Bitcoin having's more broadly
where whether or not you believe that
the price of Bitcoin having is priced in
you know Bitcoin has no marketing and
oftentimes kind of as a retail investor
as someone who's just learning about
this seeing kind of this shelling point
that everyone points to where it's like
wow I'm actually increasingly realize
that this is a and a strictly scarce
asset and that at the end of the day its
inflation is is zero right like they're
they're pre defiant and a 21 million
Bitcoin and over time you kind of just
get Bitcoin just just unlocking and
there's a debate is like is Bitcoin
created or is it discovered and so I
think that you know at the very least
what we can say is once the block
rewards have minor revenue will likely
be cut in half while minor costs will
remain constant because revenue is
denominated in Bitcoin while costs are
denominated in USD and and but that
one's kind of inefficient miners exit
the market your profit margins will
likely improve you get like a difficulty
readjustment and that will reduce
selling pressures and you'll likely see
increases in price there but in general
I think that you know it will be a
positive event I am still hesitant to
say that like you know that the having
is going to create a bull run like we've
seen historically but again only time
will tell there yeah it's gonna be
really interesting too I think because
when you start to evaluate the having I
always say that one has to happen right
so I like a lot of people I think just
assume hey it's gonna happen but we have
to see that actually occur to is the
whole idea of it being priced in would
depend on everyone knowing that it's
going to happen and also understanding
the impact that it should have right and
we all know that
not everyone even knows that it's gonna
happen that holds a Bitcoin and also
there's even less people who understand
that it's gonna happen and could explain
to you what the impact should be and so
I think it's just you know the the
debate is less about like do 100 percent
of people know or not it's more about
what percentage like how big is that
Delta between the informed and the
uninformed and there's no right answer
right we it's more of just kind of
speculation and in hindsight we'll be
able to say oh it was either priced in
or not it just seems structurally it's
really hard to make that argument but it
is priced in if 100 percent of people
don't understand it right that's that's
that's a great point I guess I would say
that what's interesting and I go back
and forth on this is that does it matter
that people are aware of the having or
does it matter that people are aware
that like bitcoin is just scarce that
there are only 21 billion right and so
the the whole value proposition behind
Bitcoin is that there are only four a
lot of people that it is this strictly
scarce asset now whether or not is
unlocked every four years or every eight
years or every two years or it's there
and and and there's just gonna be no no
further Bitcoin created I think is
secondary to actually understanding that
bitcoin is strictly scarce and so I
would say that that's where like the
pushback comes where you know it doesn't
necessarily matter that there's a
halving and what is priced in is Bitcoin
scarcity and in fact since day one
Bitcoin inflation is actually zero but
but again III go back and forth because
there's also like kind of this reflexive
property or the nature of if you have
you know a lot of people kind of banking
on is having creating a lot of buzz
around Bitcoin scarcity that can create
some very interesting kind of
second-order effects I mean even
anecdotally I had my my landlord who you
know we've spoken kind of very
high-level about Bitcoin in the past and
she
recently came across an article about
the having and she was like oh yeah you
were telling me that this thing is
scarce you know how do I buy a Bitcoin
and how do I learn about this stuff and
so that's like you know who knows like
that that might be indication that
actually you know that having is not
priced in because although someone
understands or recognizes subconsciously
that bitcoin is scarce they don't really
understand that there are these kind of
specific events in which the the
scarcity is only reinforced so I think
that that's really what it is is like a
reinforcement of scarcity that allows
almost a for a big point to market
itself as a strictly scarce for sure
speaking of digital currencies in
general there's been a bunch of changes
I think or concessions when it comes to
Libre and a lot of that was driven by
regulatory pressure which obviously part
of the value proposition of Bitcoin is
there's no CEO or founder to kind of lug
in front of government you know
organizations or Congress or anything
like that maybe talk a little bit about
how you guys have thought about Libre
and some of those recent updates to
their plans and kind of has that changed
your mind positively or negatively sure
so to your point Facebook I think last
week they unveil kind of a host of new
changes to to Libra it was actually set
to launch in this quarter but obviously
kind of given all the regulatory
pressure they you know you you had
natural delays and so I think the
biggest thing the biggest pushback that
we saw was that you know this was going
to be a stable coin backed by a basket
of fiat currencies and government bonds
but that the composition of that basket
would be to the discretion of kind of
this Libra association which is this
independent membership organization that
is designed to facilitate the operations
of the system and the administration of
the Libra Reserve and so immediately you
had Libra that was met with
extremely intense backlash from these
regulators that accused Libra of being a
massive threat to monetary sovereignty
of governments so for one I'll say an
aside I think that when we saw that I
thought I think that was like really
interesting to see kind of the
regulator's response to this and when
you look at this in the context of you
know Bitcoin ten years ago to Bitcoin
today and cryptocurrency however you
want to define that it's it's it's quite
amazing to see this shift in narrative
where you know you go from this thing is
on this random kind of email listserv
with a bunch of you know tech nerds and
this is just basic nerd money to like
you know Bitcoin and it'll actually just
being for drug lords and criminals and
terrorists to you know actually bitcoin
is new for VC to have some sort of a
mechanism to pump and dump to to now
recognizing oh wait this whole thing
whether it's Facebook or or or Bitcoin
but the idea of a cryptocurrency even if
I argued that really the only thing
related then the two RS and similar is
like their label as a cryptocurrency is
now set on the world stage and
regulators are looking at Facebook and
we're seeing kind of Facebook demise in
in that there is this almost single
point of failure where you actually have
this finger to point to where you know
Facebook naturally not being even a
crowd favorite there is not like an
excuse there is kind of this neck that
you can choke all while Bitcoin kind of
is slowly kind of working in the
background where it's if I can't kill
number one well at least let me go to
number two and so that's kind of what we
saw with this this massive backlash some
of the changes I thought were very
interesting and I think you know there's
questions of was this capitulation or
was this dependent I would say that this
is
much more because it elation when it was
a pivot a few like kind of the main
changes that were made you you had kind
of Libra singing they were going to
offer single currency stable coins
instead of kind of additional currency
coins so you basically instead of having
that basket of currencies in which in
which Libra defined the composition of
that basket you basically had of of the
currencies in that basket kind of
separate fully reserved single asset
pegs to to that coin so a Libra USD a
Libra era of libras Singaporean dollar
and so then you and so for kind of
emerging markets for developed nations
like that was that you could basically
facilitate and a value transfer without
necessarily having to shy away from the
monetary policy of that actual nation
and so Libra made sure to emphasize that
that the vision had always been for the
Libra Network to complement fiat
currencies you not compete with them
which I thought was a very interesting
concession and it also appears that
Libra now is basically just catering to
central banks where you basically have
this now it's like a platform for
central bank digital currencies where
Libra is even saying that you know we
want to be there when a new central bank
launches their own currency and have it
on our platform and so I would say that
you know we came into this kind of quiet
interested in Libra and what it was
doing and I think I think it was a very
very interesting value proposition
particularly for emerging markets
immediately we saw kind of a backlash
where you had both emerging markets like
would say India that said there's no way
this is happening and developed
nations amongst kind of nations in the
EU and the United States are saying we
do not want this to happen and so it
feels like now Libra is basically just
an e money provider for like central
bank currencies that they're that I
understand that they're kind of business
model wasn't really around kind of Libra
in particular but was around kind of
Calibra or providing kind of
infrastructure but even there like
Facebook isn't even building the
infrastructure in this newly revamped
white paper where you actually have you
actually a third party service providers
so if you live in a country that that's
lacking kind of developer presence of
Libra or you have one that's sanctioned
or restricted due to kind of libras
compliance checks which was another one
then you basically won't be able to use
that and I think that that was like the
biggest red flag for a lot of people who
thought this was going to be an
interesting way to kind of on-ramp
people into crypto that if Libra allowed
for you to export your private keys that
this would be a way for the everyday
person to see that they have full
ownership or property of these private
keys but they go and they enter it kind
of we're going to kind of enhance the
safety of this payment system with a
robust compliance framework what that
entails is we are going to basically
have it such that that any kind of sort
of any capital controls any restrictions
on specific nations must be abided by
and any kind of unholstered wallet in
specific jurisdictions will not be valid
in kind of this Libra ecosystem and so
when you think about one of the
principal reasons for having created
Libra in the first place as kind of
trying to serve this unbanked population
really as a mechanism for convenience of
payments more than as like this new
money Libre has been kind of completely
stripped of those features and and so
when you
when you have to adhere to these strict
capital controls and these regulations
then it basically just becomes like any
sort of payment processor and I it would
be interesting to see how and whether
they may do in the pivot and in calibra
could still end up being success but
they are shying away more and more from
kind of the value proposition of what
these permissionless systems are
supposed to enable and and I think their
last most notable one was kind of
completely saying that they were ago
that the transition to a permissionless
system would would no longer be within
the interest of vibra and that now we're
going to basically have kind of an
electoral based system to add new nodes
and remove nodes accordingly it is it's
one of these weird things where it seems
like Facebook legitimized Bitcoin and
crypto in certain parts of the world and
then within weeks or months also
legitimized why the decentralized
permissionless components of Bitcoin is
so valuable right it's like by just them
simply putting their their toe in the
water and saying hey we think that this
is valuable we're actually gonna build a
team here we're gonna go after this
opportunity there's a lot of people that
kind of woke up and said whoa you know a
lot of people might not like Mark
Zuckerberg but not a lot of people think
he's stupid right
and so if him in Facebook think this is
important there must be something here
but then they've dragged him in front of
Congress or Senate right you know a
bunch of other stuff that goes on and
people start to realize oh that's why
that decentralized permissionless design
is so important absolutely absolutely I
mean it's been so interesting to see to
see that you you kind of see kind of
Libre now everyone's eyes were on it
during the time that it receives such
backlash and you saw and many were
saying like this is going to end up kind
of hallucinating how much or how what
bitcoins value proposition actually is
and that is like not having kind of
these centralized governing bodies that
are enforcing top-down control but
rather these open and decentralized
networks that are providing kind of
bottom-up foundations for whatever
assurance is being provided and I think
that if anything that this will to your
point kind of opened the eyes as to
where the value propositions are and
what what people should be looking for I
think you know the JDM coin was also to
certain extent a similar example to that
where you know they label it as a
cryptocurrency when it was really just a
USD account for institutions and and and
said okay this is a cryptocurrency this
allowed for a lot of people who didn't
consider this to be worthy of
exploration to say oh wow well if JP
Morgan is now coming out with something
called a cryptocurrency I probably
should look into this and upon looking
into this you start to realize just how
different it is from let's say Bitcoin
and in doing so you you realize okay
well actually I think bitcoin is the
most interesting thing of all so it's
it's free marketing I would say for for
a lot of these cryptocurrencies we will
take it speaking of other
cryptocurrencies before we finish up
ether and the etherium community I know
you have a bunch of thoughts there may
be sure kind of what you guys are
thinking
and the second most popular
cryptocurrency sure so no I think that
aetherium is increasingly starting to
realize like the importance of having
ether the underlying asset as as showing
that it is a money you know we were very
similar to how kind of big coin went
through growing pains around its
narratives you know is this a cash
system is this a p2p digital cold you
know theorem is starting to realize kind
of these same things okay maybe it's not
a world computer maybe this is native
acid that can
an economy of decentralized finance or
whatever the cases I would say that from
a from a value of cruel standpoint from
an investment standpoint there is an
increasing realization that you know
value capture does not equal value
creation but again these
cryptocurrencies are not productive
assets that that a lot of the value is
actually going to be driven by
reservation demand by the willingness
told and I like to view aetherium
although I don't think that you know
over the long term I do think that
bitcoin is going to kind of accrue more
value in a power law distributed manner
and then the theory of might I like to
view aetherium in the in the eyes and
actually etherium killers it very
similar to how bitcoiners view etherion
there's a there's a really really
interesting kind of bridge that in that
is being that is being formed where very
similar to how the big corners you
etherium Zod's that you serving it
if theory ins are now viewing your
killer's odds at you serving it in the
same way so we saw kind of a number of
these aetherium killers that were
planning to launch their maintenance
where you you saw like you know the
algorithms of the world the hash graphs
of the world that that had a lot of
promise and that obviously in bull
markets you know anything tends to trade
up we saw him yes you you know when
Bitcoin was trade everybody was trading
at you know like nineteen twenty billion
dollars market cap or one hundred thirty
billion dollars in market cap you had
you had like the cardano's and the EEO
C's of the world who hadn't even
launched her main net that were trading
at ten twenty billion dollars so you had
very very questionable fundamentals but
but you know price really didn't reflect
that in bear markets we're starting to
see is that the disposition is
definitely to trade down and so what's
interesting is that a lot of Syrians are
now saying that it's very very
hard to justify evaluations for these
etherium killers based on kind of
superior technology alone so what we've
seen is that a theorem is basically
saying it doesn't matter you know
whether or not you have this next
etherion killer that can provide much
more smart contract option at endearing
can't because look at aetherium
developer activity look at its network's
effects in Tim's credit it has built out
a robust set of stakeholders since main
that and and far more successfully than
any sort of appearing killer but if you
notice kind of the tone I think that
this tone we're starting to we saw with
big congress's theorem we start seeing
the theorem versus a theorem killers
Bitcoin in the same way says that you
know in the open source world technology
is nowhere near kind of a defensible
kind of moat as to what we traditionally
see what theories are now applying that
same logic to fear and killers and so we
understand kind of the characteristics
of let's say proof of work based
commodities like we're seeing in here in
1.0 and and Bitcoin there is yet to be
kind of robust literature and and and
validation around kind of more proof of
state-created capital assets but I just
find that the tone that the theory ins
are now applying to fearing killers to
be very reminiscent of what they
couldn't have been saying school-time
and this kind of really just goes back
to what these are and and where most
value is going to accrue is going to
depend on kind of the network effects
that these that these assets have been
able to build and the willingness to
hold these assets more broadly yeah it
is the most fascinating part of all of
crypto to me is the debate between the
technology versus the belief system and
I think part of what has surprised me
you know having a background working as
some of the large tech companies and
understanding a lot of that community in
eCos
and then also on the wall street sign
the finance community they look at these
problems very differently right they're
very biased in their perceptions but in
some weird way the finance people
understand money much better than most
technology but in this you know big over
generalization but definitely to some
degree and it's almost like the winner
of the debate ran a couple winner in air
quotes is going to be is it just money
that matters and all the properties that
come along with that or is it the
technology that matters and all the
things that come with that I think you
and I have a perspective but I don't
know if that debate has been settled in
the sense of there's a market consensus
which then that meets the opportunity
right is there's people kind of betting
on both sides of both assets and there
will be winners and losers over a long
period of time absolutely - completely
different philosophies I don't think one
is right or wrong I just think that it's
important to delineate between the two
and if I were to kind of just from a
risk to reward standpoint you know look
at you know historically how a lot of
these other crypto assets have been kind
of levered beta plays on Bitcoin that
within the cryptocurrency community
there is still pretty strong core luck
correlation that if you if you're like
an institutional investor and you're
looking to kind of allocate into the
crypto space I think you have to first
be convinced a Bitcoin before anything
else and then we look at where most
value is going to accrue and you start
to recognize this from a monetary lens
it it's hard to justify from a
risk/reward standpoint allocating at
least in the foreseeable future into
things other than Bitcoin having said
that you know let's say 10 20 years down
the line if the whole kind of internet
300 deesis does play out and there are
kind of interesting implications on
reversing the internet stack and
figuring out ways to kind of further
disintermediate data providers they're
there
some very very interesting VC type pets
but I think that they're very I think
the the way that most value is going to
accrue is quite paradoxical to what we
see in traditional venture capital of
kind of the pray and spray model that
that most pcs employ their now kind of
employing to the crypto space but again
this is an ongoing debate I think that
it is very very interesting and to see
kind of the value of cruel dynamics
evolve over time really just goes to
show that only time will tell
long Bitcoin man
before we end I'm gonna surprise you
with something that you don't know
because since we started recording when
we were started recording oil was at
about $10 a barrel and it is now
negative it has literally dropped to
under $0 and it's currently crude oil is
currently trading at negative $1 43
people are texting me so pretty nuts
happen Peak Oil demanding around 2022 so
we're close to that he was like trading
at 60 or $70 barrel that when we said 10
to $15 people were an absolute shock
like there's no way and like kind of
Kathy likes to say you have commodities
that are usually priced at the margin
and you know things like kind of the
extra electric vehicle and on this angle
I think is also kind of contributing to
just this complete cascading effect that
we've seen obviously you know you know
that's just I mean I'm blown away
I don't look at my phone four times
because I was like what no you mean it's
negative all right where can people find
you on on the Internet and any of the
researcher work that you you're putting
out sure so you can find an arc at arc -
and best calm where else on Twitter I'm
you seen arc AR K and and we have
bunch of our because its own Twitter
account and all of our analysts are also
on Twitter so feel free to join us on
the Twittersphere
yeah you guys are fantastic I uh I said
it with Kathy but I just appreciate the
kind of data-driven research driven
approach to innovative technology
because it's funny how if you do the
work the data tells you some of the
answers right thank you well I really do
appreciate it and I was saying this for
long Bitcoin for at the bank's quoted
pump so thanks for everything that you
do I think that you know a lot of people
who aren't relatively familiar with
everything that's going on in the
investing world now more broadly you
find a lot of value and and just and
listening to the things that you have to
say and the guests that you bring on and
every one of my friends who's not in the
investment world always asks what's a
good resource for me to just start to
you know that I dabble in in the
investing world and you're definitely
one of the first that I bring up so
appreciate all your efforts as well I
appreciate that very much
well we will we will continue to do this
as long as we continue to debate all
these ideas so I appreciate taking the
time to let join us today thank you sir
have a great one and stay safe